andreas comme tous les soirs il revient
sur tout ce qui s'est passé et
aujourd'hui nous fait les télés locales
je vous le dis c'est le bureau de
recherche et vous allez voir de caler
dans la rue c'est très très drôle aussi
andreas commentcamarche irénique la sava
et toi tu es en train d'exploser dans le
parfum ça devient sans rigoler alors tu
connais un petit peu d équipes je vois
la luce et benjamin castaldi c'est qui
delphine il a perdu delphine wespiser il
ya sont comme derrière
[Musique]
alors oui les gens michel jean michel
maire maxime oui là je dirais muchacho
ouais ça à regarder
daniel emma côté matthieu vesques
immédiat réglages pas restent sûrs
d'être moins bon et très intimidée ski à
ta présence veut l'entendre aussi j'ai
déjà été fait sous enquête chez vous
pour être gardé chez elle et qui donc
s'est pas dit si le sait plus non
christine kelly
c'est ce que j'ai dit mais bon le plus
gentil avec moi j'ai oublié son plein
mais c'est souvent comme ça c'est qu'il
ya derrière dépendance est derrière ce
qui n'a rien d'acquis lee mcclenny vous
kiffe un peu un cache pas que c'est
réciproque
[Applaudissements]
voilà maxime gainey désolé mais maxime
labat en mai désolé il n'y a pas de
potes comme ça vous danserez un petit
saut demain d'accord pas mal et alors
maintenant ce serait un seul os mac
ah oui je suis là demain je suis dit je
suis là allez c'est parti on y va j'ai
regardé les télés locales du coup j'ai
essayé de comprendre pourquoi ça marche
et genre un tout petit peu moins bien
que tf1 tu fais et je crois que j'ai un
début de réponse je suis passé sur tv8
mont blanc et vous allez voir dans
l'émission qui suivent l'animateur pour
mettre en confiance ses invités à
décider à l'antenne de boire un petit
verre avec eux ou 2 ou douze tables où
on va boire un coup le problème c'est
qu'au bout d'un moment l'animateur a
commencé à fatiguer et ça s'est ressenti
un peu dans sa diction et la planète
entière va vivre au rythme de star wars
huit jours plus rien dire du tout pc via
roma gps.com on leur offre des places
pour les voir starwizz on peut quand
même j'essaie 8 dans les oreilles
voilà parce que vous savez la chaîne en
fait ils sont enrichis et donc ils
disent oui il faut dire l'alcool est
dangereux pour les gens pour des débiles
rentrer chez eux
allez des télés locales et sur grand
lille tv zune interviewé en fan de
johnny et l'idéal fans dans l'attitude
fans dans le look de johnny hallyday par
contre dans la voix c'est plutôt fan de
mon tonton jean louis
la très belle la fois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais pas de johnny du coup ensuite je
suis passé sur 1 2 3 musette pour ceux
qui connaissent pas c'est loïc machine
mais des gens qui kiffent le bal musette
laisse regarder alors en termes de
génériques qui n'ont rien à envier aux
grosses productions keep the voice ou
danse avec les stars 1 c'est le même
budget
c'est agace
bon alors le principe dans les émissions
musicales c'est que l'artiste doit faire
sa promo sauf quand un qui lui est pas
super chaud pour ne pas vous jouez
également de la trompe de chasse
un mot sur cet instrument bourreau
maxime tout quand je suis passé sur les
papys flingueurs le concept est simple
lancer des pâquis qui se réunissent pour
décrypter la q1 blême l'animateur a
tendance à les confondre un peu entre
eux face et ses champs de l'awalé
maintenant je le salue
on a une sous le papier flingueurs il ya
quelqu'un qui a voulu la chine
malheureusement les animateurs pour
clôturer le dos a décidé de sortir de
l'intérim il vaut mieux vaudrait mieux
manger une bonne chose c'est à dire un
bon politique
tu t'es une grosse chez moi oui mr s'est
produit l'antenne après ben normal
bon après ça je suis allé poser des
questions aux gens dans la rue masséna
d'or problème c'est que moi mon délire
j'aurais voulu devenir le grand
journaliste d'investigation ouais
problème c'est que dans les rues je
trouve pas forcément des gens pour
répondre à mes questions profondes
du coup pour les appâter je leur laisse
parler de leur sujet de prédilection
mais juste avant de passer à l'antenne
je change un poil la question ça allait
mais un peu en galère regardez là si je
me trompe pas tu étais en train de
danser à l'import correctement pour en
parler un petit peu de danse et tout ça
est prêt à nous répondre alors que le
débat fait pas on a alors commencé dans
le catalogue de 1 tapez antennes alors
je suis avec le jeune clinique avec
beaucoup de courage a accepté de nous
parler de son changement de sexe il y
est encore alors on marilyn clé ni du
coup pourquoi je suis décidé de changer
de sexe savoir en gros sur le climat
vous seriez prête à me répondre
ça sera pour ces huit vous inquiétez pas
je suis actuellement avec karine qui
avec beaucoup de courage à dessiner nous
expliquer pourquoi elle a décidé de
devenir le sosie de michel polnareff
pourquoi
vous avez décidé de devenir le sosie de
michel polnareff ça va lui coller la
nuit si vous pensez que les français qui
chassent et ça vous dérange pas de me
donner cette réponse alors je suis avec
anne qui sut saisir deux filles de bonne
famille a décidé en acte de rébellion
d'uriner sur les véhicules de police
pardon je venais sur le véhicule des
policiers non il n'en est absolument pas
question
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]